dans l'épisode précédent on a vu le
fonctionnement et l'importance de la
descente de gradient pour le
développement d'une intelligence
artificielle de façon grossière la
descente de gradient permet
l'exploration guide et d'algorithmes de
grande complexité
ce qui si l'on en croit turine est
indispensable à la conception dire de
niveau humain et dans l'épisode d'encore
avant j'ai suggéré que l'efficacité
stupéfiante des réseaux de neurones
s'expliquait en grande partie par leur
aptitude à se prêter merveilleusement
bien à la descente de gradient et sas
avait en particulier d'une formule
mathématique appelé la dérive et des
fonctions composés qui dans le cadre des
réseaux de neurones a été depuis
renommée algorithmes de rétro
propagation ou bac propagation ou juste
bac propre en anglais c'est cet
algorithme qui permet aux réseaux de
neurones de calculer rapidement et
efficacement les gradients qui
permettront ensuite d'ajuster les
paramètres de ces réseaux de neurones
pour mieux expliquer les données avant
de commencer leur aplomb comment un
réseau de neurones effectué des
prédictions
pour ce faire il prend des informations
en entrée via sa première couche de nos
rhône puis une suite d'opérations des
neurones et de transmission de messages
via les synapses des neurones conduit à
une certaine activation des neurones de
la dernière couche on a aussi vu que la
suite et d'activation neuronale du
cerveau dépend des deux trois types de
paramètres premièrement il ya les
fonctions d'activation des neurones
ensuite il ya les billets des neurones
enfin chaque synapses est associé à un
poids qui fait de la synapse une synapse
plus ou moins inhibitrice ou plus ou
moins activatrice alors les fonctions
d'activation généralement on n'y touche
pas du coup les paramètres du réseau
sont au final les billets des neurones
et les pois synaptique qui correspondent
à une grande collection de boutons à
tourner il faut donc imaginer qu'un
réseau de neurones est une immense
machine avec un bouton par synapse et
par neurones et comme on l'a vu la
dernière fois un gradient doit nous dire
dans quelle direction et à quel point il
faut tourner les bouton de la machine
imaginons pour simplifier le cas où le
réseau de neurones doit prédire la
présence ou l'absence de chats dans une
image ou donne alors une image que chat
aux réseaux de neurones qui effectue ses
calculs complexes pour conclure que
l'image une probabilité 0,6 de contenir
penchard 0,6 c'est pas mal mais
idéalement on aimerait que le réseau de
neurones conclu que l'image est une
probabilité un de contenir un chat comme
on l'a vu on peut mesurer l'erreur du
réseau par le carré de l'écart contre la
prédiction et laval
attendu dans notre cas et pour cette
image le réseau de neurones a donc une
pénalité un mois 0,6 au carré qui est
égale à 0,4 au carré est égal à 0,16 ça
fait cool ça nous donne la performance
du réseau de neurones mais ça ne vous
dit pas que faire pour améliorer le
réseau de neurones
or pour faire de l'apprentissage c'est
justement les modifications désirable
des paramètres du réseau de neurones
qu'il nous faut déterminer de façon
cruciale
le réseau de neurones peut également
déterminer à quel point il faudrait que
son dernier run s'activent davantage
intuitivement plus paix est loin de 1
pour une image de chats plus il est
urgent d'augmenter la valeur de paix les
matheux parmi vous savent que cette
urgence a augmenté p correspond à la
dérive et de la pénalité
1 - p au carré par rapport à pec qui va
être ici égale à 2 x 1 - b autrement dit
de façon plus intuitive ça veut dire que
piper est loin de 1
plus il ya urgence à augmenter sa valeur
dans notre cap est égal à 0,6 ça nous
fait une urgence a augmenté p qui est
égale à deux fois 0,4 qui est égal à 0,8
ok on sait l'urgence à modifier
l'activation du dernier neurones mais
tout ceci ne nous dit rien sur comment
modifier les boutons on y vient en effet
étant donné la fonction d'activation du
neurone le neurone peut alors déterminer
comment ce qu'il a reçu devra être
modifié pour que le neurone se mettent
davantage à s'activer alors
techniquement ça correspond quelqu'un
que je mets à l'écran mais de façon
intuitive si une grande variation
positive du signal entrant dans le nord-
on cause une grande variation positive
du signal sortant sachant qu'il ya une
urgence plus 0,8 à modifier le signal
sortant alors il y aura une urgence plus
0,8 à modifier le signal entrant si
maintenant une petite variation positive
du signal entrant cause une grande
variation positive du signal sortant
alors l'urgence a modifié le signal
entrant sera encore plus grande
peut-être de l'ordre de + 2 car même une
infime variation de ce signal entrant
pourrait régler notre problème
enfin à l inverse une énorme variation
positive du signal entrant ne change pas
grand chose au signal sortant alors il
n'y aura aucune urgence à modifier au
signal rentrant puisque celui ci n'a de
toute façon que peu d'effet ce que j'ai
décrit la intuitivement est vraiment le
coeur du théorème des fonctions composer
et je vous renvoie vers cette excellente
vidéo de tribus
pour affiner votre intuition du problème
on a tout ce qu'il faut pour ajuster le
premier de nos paramètres on va voir
comment ajuster le biais du dernier
neurones en effet le neurone sait
exactement de quoi est composé son
signal entrant on l'a vu il s'agit d'une
combinaison linéaire de contribution des
synapses pente raide et du biais du
noron sache en effet immédiat du biais
du neurone sur le signal entrant de
neurones peut aisément déduire l'urgence
a modifié son billet cette urgence sera
en fait égal à l'urgence a modifié le
signal entrant venons en maintenant aux
synapses pour rappel leur contribution
se décompose comme le produit de
l'intensité du message qui traverse la
synapse par le coefficient inhibiteur ou
activateur de la synapse
imaginons qu'un message de très grande
intensité et traverser la synapse
on voit alors que le coefficient
activateur de la synapse va jouer un
rôle primordial
il va donc être urgent d'ajuster en
effet sachant que le message d'une très
grande intensité toutes légères
modifications positives du signal
activateur de la synapse va causer une
grande variation positive du signal
entrons du nord
ainsi de façon générale pour toutes
synapses activatrice qui a conduit un
message de grande intensité
il y aura alors urgence à augmenter le
coefficient activateur de la synapse
n'est une remarque similaire pour tout
synapses inhibitrice qui a conduit à un
message de grande intensité en diminuant
légèrement le coefficient inhibiteurs de
cette synapses on enlève une grande
contribution ou bi triste ce qui
augmente grandement le signal entrant de
la synapse comme il ya urgence à
augmenter ce signal entrant il y à
encore plus urgence à diminuer le
coefficient inhibiteur de la synapse
voir à rendre la synapse activatrice au
lieu d'être finie maîtrise en
considérant qu une synapse inhibitrice
correspond à un point négatif qui sera
d'autant plus négative que la synapse et
inhibitrice tout notre discussion
revient simplement à dire que si
l'intensité d'un message est très grand
et si il y a urgence à augmenter le
signal entrant alors il ya urgence à
augmenter le poids de la synapse à
travers laquelle le message est passé
al'inverse bien sûr si le message qui a
traversé une synapse et d'intensité
faible ou quasi nulle alors il n'y aura
aucune urgence à modifier le poids de la
synapse
bref on vient de voir comment modifier
les boutons qui correspondent aux biais
du
arni neurones et aux synapses qui vont
vers ce dernier neurones mais le génie
de la rétro propagation c'est de faire
remonter l'information sur les urgences
à modifier les paramètres des neurones
et des synapses vers les couches
précédente
et pour cela il nous faut maintenant
étudier l'urgence à modifier non pas les
poids des synapses précédent le neurone
finale mais l'urgence à modifier
l'intensité des messages qui traverse
ses synapses considérons une synapse
très activatrice on voit alors que
l'intensité du message va avoir une
énorme influence positive sur le signal
entrant du neurone en effet une légère
augmentation de l'intensité du message
l'a grandement augmenté de signal
entrant du neurone mais du coup ça veut
dire qu'il y aura une urgence a augmenté
de l'activation des neurones à l'origine
du message qui a traversé la synapse et
bien sûr l inverse si une synapse et
très inhibitrice et s'il ya urgence à
augmenter l'activation du signal poste
synaptique
alors il y aura urgence à diminuer
l'activation du neurone très synaptique
c'est là toute l'astuce de la rétro
propagation parce qu'on sait l influence
de l'activation d'un neurone sur
l'activation des neurones qui le suivent
étant donné l'urgence à modifier
l'activation des neurones en bout de
ligne on peut remonter l'information est
déterminé l'urgence à modifier
l'activation des neurones des premières
couches alors là pour l'avant dernière
couche chaque neurone reçoit
l'information que d'un neurone de la
couche suivante mais bien sûr dans
lequel général chaque neurone va
recevoir une combinaison de messages des
neurones de la couche suivante qui
l'informent de l'urgence ou non de
diminuer ou augmenter son activation le
neurone valeur déterminer comment
changer son activation en prenant tout
simplement la somme des messages qui lui
sont remontés ce faisant chaque neurone
se retrouve dans la situation du dernier
neurones dont on a déjà parlé
étant donné l'urgence qu'il ya à
davantage s'activer ou à - s'activer
chaque neurone va déterminer l'urgence a
modifié son signal entrant et donc à
modifier son billet les poids des
synapses entrantes et à modifier
l'activation des neurones qui le précède
alors dernier point un peu technique on
vient en fait de calculer le gradient du
réseau de neurones vis à vis de sa
prédiction pour une image donnée
pour calculer le gradient du réseau de
neurones vis-à-vis de ses prédictions
pour tout un jeu de données
il suffit en fait de calculer les
gradients vis-à-vis de chacune des
données et de prendre ensuite la moyenne
de tous et gradient en fait ce qui
montre là c'est surtout que les réseaux
de neurones se prêtent particulièrement
bien non pas la descente de gradient en
tant que tel mais plutôt à la descente
de gradient it stochastiques
bref si j'essaie de résumer un réseau de
neurones fonctionne finalement un peu
comme une organisation hiérarchique pour
fabriquer quelque chose on va avoir des
messages qui vont des décideurs aux
hommes de terrain
mais pour améliorer la fabrication
globale il est crucial que les hommes de
terrain fasse remonter l'information de
ce qui doit être amélioré sur le terrain
pour que les décideurs combine ces
informations et puissent améliorer le
processus de fabrication et la magie des
réseaux de neurones c'est de permettre
cela entre des entités aussi basiques
que des neurones
chaque neurone peut même fonctionner
indépendamment sans se préoccuper du
fonctionnement global du réseau de
neurones et néanmoins malgré cette façon
très décentralisé de traiter
l'information de façon merveilleuse le
réseau de neurones dans son entièreté
demeure capable de calculer des
gradients ce qui revient à déterminer
comment ajuster au mieux ces paramètres
ce qui permet l'exploration guidée des
réglages de sa machinerie et il semble
bien que ce soit cette très jolie
prouesse qui soit le coeur du succès des
réseaux de neurones moderne
là enfin on avait parlé d'aller centre
de gradient stochastique et on avait
notamment mesuré les performances de la
machine avec le pkr est où un mot opéré
en fonction de mios kpatcha et j'ai un
login bergen demande est ce que ce choix
et son c est ce qu on pourrait pas tout
simplement passés par péan - paie mieux
de mettre tous et au carré ça changerait
quoi en fait ça faudrait pas à
grand-chose fonctionnement en
particulier ce changement ne nagerai
absolument pas les calculs en tout cas
de descente de grézan puisque c'est
vraiment la partie en partant de
l'apprentissage cca descente de gradient
puisque la fonction objectif en faudra
avoir la décence de gardiens comme cette
façon de guider l'apprentissage est
finalement guidé avec pk ray ou p ça
change pas énormément de choses
j'aurais même tendance à dire que m au
caire et en fait c'est légèrement mieux
puisque ça permet d'insister un peu plus
sur le fait que par exemple peut dire
prot a été égalé 0,9 quand il ya une
image sans chat c'est vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup moins bien que dire 0.5 et le
fait de mettre ça au carré permet de
faire ressentir le beaucoup beaucoup
moins bien d'une certaine manière
un autre point qui pourrait être
intéressant à signaler c'est que ici on
a fait on a des images quand on sait
s'il y un chat ou s'il n'y a pas de chat
et en pratique on peut imaginer que au
lieu de dire s'il ya un chat aussi à
pâtir en fait il ya une incertitude nous
autres humains qu'on voit une image
il est possible que l'image soit elle
que cela soit difficile de savoir si un
chat ou s'il n'y a pas de choix est
plutôt que de dire aux réseaux de nankin
bonnes réponses et pégase 0 ou pigalle
un lien possible qu' il soit mieux que
de dire que la bonne réponse dans
certains cas c'est une valeur qui est
strictement entre 0 et 1
et ça ce principe est en fait très liée
aux générative adversaire networks au
haut de gamme qui sont vraiment en ce
moment la superstar du machine learning
et dont on reparlera dans le rhin futurs
épisodes et dans le cas du gan il se
trouve qu'en fait utiliser le carré est
pas une très bonne idée et on a tendance
plutôt utiliser ce qu'on appelle la
divergence qu'at elle donc ça j'en parle
dans mon livre et on en parlera très
brièvement dans un futur épisode de sant
forum fument ils nous demandent ne
signera pas de meilleures méthodes que
la descente de gradient stochastique y
parle notamment de la méthode de newton
alors la méthode de newton je vais pas
expliquer dans les détails ce que c'est
ça avoir avec exploite aussi la courbure
de la fonction plutôt que juste la pente
de la fonction donc la pointe soit
arrivée première la courbure s'appelle
dérivée seconde également et en
utilisant ces deux informations en fait
on est capable de démontrer que la
descente qu'on obtient la méthode de
newton va converger plus vite que la
descente de gradient en tout cas dans le
cas des fonctions de convection je suis
désolé de dire des mots un peu technique
tout ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est
qu'il existe des méthodes qui après
marche au mieux que la descente de
gradient mais pour que ces méthodes de
marche mieux en fait il est assez
indispensable de faire des calculs qui
sont supplémentaires et en particulier
de faire ses calculs de dérivés secondes
qui sont extrêmement difficiles à faire
dans un réseau de neurones et en
particulier le temps de calcul sera a
priori quadratique ans le nombre de
paramètres de votre machine
car à moins que vous aurez réussi à
trouver une machine demain qui soit une
alternative aux réseaux neurones dont on
peut calculer les dérivés seconde en
autant qu'ils aient pas quadratique en
nombre de paramètres
j'ai bien peur que ces méthodes d'ordre
supérieur comme les appelle sont des
méthodes qui ne seront pas applicables
en pratique parce qu'il faut imaginer
que les réseaux de neurones vont avoir
ont déjà des milliards de paramètres les
plus gros d'entre eux donc si on a un
temps des calculs quadratique ça veut
dire qu'il faut faire un milliard de
milliards d'opérations et un milliard de
milliards d'opérations c'est quelque
chose qui est absolument pas faisable
avec les technologies d'aujourd'hui fin
ça prendra un temps vraiment vraiment
fou il faudrait voir venir paralléliser
calculs et on pourrait pas à faire
beaucoup d'itérations de la méthode de
luton bref tout ça pour dire qu'en fait
la descente de gradient parce qu'elle a
un temps de calcul assez rapide comme on
l'a vu en gros il suffit que chaque
neurone façon groupe quelques une
poignée d'opérations qu'en gros le temps
de calcul sera linéaire en le nombre de
paramètres donc c'est l'ordre du
milliard d'opérations et avec des
ordinateurs d'aujourd'hui milliards
d'opérations à ça ça prend une seconde
donc ça c'est tout à fait raisonnable
toutes ces remarques font que la
descente de gradient sera certainement
un studio et parler ce sera très
certainement en avis un composant
fondamental d intelligence artificielle
du futur ce sera sans doute pas le seul
mais ce sera sans doute un composant
central des intelligences artificielles
du futur et ça ça m'amène au petit
sondage qui l'avait fait sur twitter
vous avez demandé de parier sur la
probabilité que le cerveau humain
utilise quelque chose comme la descente
de gradient toro stochastique est ce qui
est assez étonnant de voir c'est que il
ya beaucoup de désaccord c'est à dire
que on est très loin d'un truc où les
gens ne savent pas ils mettent environ
50 %
en fait il ya vous n'êtes pas mal être
dans l'incertitude avec m entre 10 % et
90 % mais la plupart d'entre vous met
des valeurs quand même assez extrêmes et
moi j'aurais trouvé ça va tu m'as l'air
assez extrêmes également correctement ça
met plus de 90%
parce qu'il me semble vraiment que le
raisonnement
de turing à la base est extrêmement
convaincant et que la descente de
gradient est vraiment le chaînon
manquant qui manquait au raisonnement de
turing qui permet cette exploration des
espaces d'algorithmes à forte complexité
de solomonoff ou baru demande quel est
le lien entre la forme et la descente de
gradient et bien il y en a un et il ya
même un article qui est sorti en 2016
qui dont le titre est tout simplement la
descente de gradient stochastique en
tant que inférences bayésienne approcher
une conférence balise argos et à
formuler à les appliquer de façon
approcher est ce que cet article montre
en fait c'est que notamment le fait de
ne pas converger le fait de ne pas
arriver un minimum global avec la
descente de gradient stochastique est
une très bonne chose et c'est ça qui
fait qu'en fait on exporte plusieurs
modèles et qu'on peut prendre ensuite la
moyenne de ces modèles pour avoir une
élection qui serait beaucoup plus
béziers donc la décote décembre de grade
notamment stochastique en fait un
fondement à ces balises hien donc ça
c'est un des aspects qui fait qu'elles
sont de gradient paraît très belle et
zen
un autre aspect si on légalise les
geraghty va du rock se trouvant par là
dans une prochaine vidéo
enfin le proviseur a commenté par
rapport à l'hypothèse de riemann qui est
un peu le gros truc de la semaine
dernière donc là au moment je filme on
est mardi donc la preuve de l'hypothèse
de riemann a été révélée par michael
attiyah hier donc je sais pas trop ce
qui s'est passé dans le reste de la
semaine
mais alors qu'il est j'aurais tendance à
parier comme beaucoup de gens d'ailleurs
que l'hypothèse de riemann en fait n'a
pas été démontrée par à kia pas ce qui
me semble assez probable donc dans un
des commentaires youtube et je pense
vraiment en ce moment là je suis en
train de parler à 99% que l'hypothèse de
riemann n'est en fait n'a pas été
prouvée malheureusement paradis avec qui
il ya une erreur quelque part dans son
raisonnement
donc ce préjugé que j'espère à ses
balises est un que j'ai n'ai absolument
pas fondée sur la preuve elle même parce
que je comprends absolument pas la
preuve donc je ne sais pas capable du
dew de juger à la preuve en tout cas
mardi aujourd'hui il ya assez peu de
gens qui
ont émis un avis sur la preuve il y en a
quelques-uns notamment sur twitter et
qui questionne notamment un truc
s'appelle les fonctions de todd qui
aurait l'air d'être un composant central
qui sont un composant central de la
preuve d'atiyah et malheureusement ses
fonctions le toit de peuvent pourrait
être problématique d'après certains
mathématicien sur twitter et ce qui est
assez bizarre c'est que la manière dont
attiyah a introduit ses fonctions il a
fait ça sur deux papiers différents de
manière assez bancal il a en plus dans
le premier de ses papiers sur la
structure fine il fait des prédictions
sur la valeur de cette constante de
structures fines qui sont pas du tout
les bonnes valeurs de la physique c'est
d'après certaines simulations qui tourne
notamment sur edith et sur twitter
bref il ya quelque chose qui a alerte
pas très clair dans la preuve des tirs
donc voilà on est mardi
c'est un petit peu embêtant parce que
vous voyez ça une semaine plus tard et
peut-être que voilà vous regardez cette
vidéo on sait que l'hypothèse de riemann
n'a pas été prouvée paratilla ou
peut-être qu'on sait que rien n'a été
prouvé ou qu'elle est juste mais en tout
cas en ce moment martèle j'ai tendance à
dire que très probablement elle n'est
pas juste il reste quand même un petit
soupçon pas ce que vont peut-être que
les commentateurs sur twitter ce ne sont
pas du tout fiable à 100% a priori c'est
possible d'argent qu'eux aussi ils font
face des erreurs dans leur jugement de
la preuve est également qu' il n'est pas
bien compris toutes les idées des tirs
at il à l'air très sûr de lui donc voilà
ça je mettrai pas même un petit pour
cent que la preuve de tillard est juste
mais ça sent pas très bon elle espère
que j'avais aimé cette vidéo la
prochaine fois on va étudier un peu les
propriétés de la descente de gradient
avec une approche un peu plus
géométriques et notamment on va se
demander si cette descente de gradient
permet vraiment d'atteindre
global ou peut-être que ça atteint 14
min un blocage voir ce qu'on appelle des
points c'est l'on parlera de tout ça
d'après une fois ça fera des liens avec
la topographie et la montagne
si vous avez aimé cet épisode penser à
la ligue et à l'augmenter à le partager
pensez à vous abonner pour ne pas
manquer futurs épisodes merci un petit
peur paulo redon et j'espère que vous
serez là la prochaine fois et si vous
devez apprendre la dérive est la pire
chose que vous pourriez faire un sens
c'est ne vous reposer que sur une seule
interprétation de la dérive et en
particulier dans cette vidéo précédente
je vous ai donné cette interprétation
différente du concept de dérivés et ce
qu'il vous reste à faire si non
seulement comprendre chacune des
interprétations mais surtout de faire le
lien entre les différentes
interprétations
[Musique]